this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by Simply Safe there's no safe
like Simply
Safe The Book of Revelation says the end
of the world will be announced with the
sound of seven trumpets each blowing of
the trumpet brings a new apocalyptic
event after the seventh trumpet
Armageddon for centuries people have
reported lowf frequency hums the crack
of thunder on a clear day and the sound
of cannon fire in the middle of nowhere
mysterious sounds have been heard at the
bottom of the ocean and in outer space
and they've been heard long before
modern machines and Industry recently
people have been recording and sharing
videos of these loud unnatural sounds
and some of them they sound a lot like
[Music]
trumpets no I'm sorry Mrs McGill Cy that
that box was probably meant for my house
yeah no I I didn't order a case of
champagne it was prob yeah human thank
goodness you're there give me a minute
I'll come get it let me guess it's an
emergency stop with this sarcasm this is
an emergency okay okay here's what he
needs you to do grab your Polaroid
camera leave your cell phone at the
studio go to the valet at the Golden
Nugget and say I lost my shirt at crabs
he'll give you the keys to a van that'll
be parked in front of the Elvis wedding
chapel then get in and look under the
bobblehead camel on the dash follow the
written directions to my location and
when you arrive knock the first three
lines of the gbur dress and mor coat on
the door so I know it's you yeah but I
never lost my shirt in craps that's all
you heard I'm in real trouble over here
okay what's going on look look you know
I enjoy hosting a wi files but I think
my immense Fame has one tiny draw back I
have a stalker I'm sure that you don't
have a stalker and hang on you don't
host the wi files I host the wi files
yeah whatever you got to tell yourself
to sleep at night pal and I absolutely
do this weirdo and a van keeps showing
up at my house really that that is a
little scary he keeps leaving me boxes
full of gifts I get stuff I talk about
on the show things I really want
yesterday when I came home there were
boxes inside my bowl just get a security
system from Simply Safe how does this
abrupt shift in tone indicate it's time
for today's sponsor well you bet your
sweet dorsal fin it does Simply Safe is
comprehensive security for the whole
home they've got sensors and cameras to
protect you from break-ins floods fires
yeah but what do I do if I see on the
cameras well Simply Safe has 24/7 live
guard protection professional monitoring
agents that can see and speak live to
Intruders in your home and their Smart
Alarm indoor camera is the only camera
that can trigger the alarm and blare a
built-in siren oh I can blare an alarm
and yell insults at them that'll get
their attention it sure will and the
system is super easy to install yourself
but they also have Professional
installation available and the entire
system can be controlled with the Simply
Safe app oh yeah this all sounds great
great but the last time I used an alarm
company I had to deal with contracts and
all these extra costs well Simply Safe
never locks you into a long-term
contract or charges hidden fees
professional monitoring plans are
available for less than $1 a day I'm
sold did they give us one of those ideal
thingies yep save 20% on your system and
your first month is free when you sign
up for fast protect monitoring just go
to simplysafe
[Music]
SL the wi files that's it okay I got to
get this done before my stalker shows up
again he's easy to see cuz he always
brings his gifts in a brown van and
wears a matching brown shirt and shorts
uh brown shirt brown shorts Brown van oh
yeah the van has yellow writing on the
side it's so creepy that he brings
exactly what I want every time he must
have a camera in my bowl oh maybe a
listening device I need to call my buddy
at the embassy it's time for another bug
sweep in here well how much vodka is in
your bowl you know that you black out
right um well the last time you went on
an online shopping binge I ended up with
a waterproof turntable a strobe light
and a disco ball all on my porch yeah
and you know how awkward it was to
explain the brass Pole to my neighbors
but that was exercise
equipment uh okay I got to go sign up
for Simply Safe I can't believe I did
that again it's going to take me forever
to pay off that underwater sound
system
The Book of Revelation 8 describes the
opening of the seventh seal which
contains seven trumpets to be sounded By
Angels and I saw the seven angels who
stand before God and seven trumpets were
given to them then the seven angels who
had the seven trumpets prepared to sound
them oh seven trumpets if these angels
want to form a decent jazz band they're
also going to need a trombone a banjo
and and a pretty good drummer uh the
sounding of the trumpets in Revelation
signals the apocalypse not the formation
of a jazz band you sure the Bible's not
talking about a jazz band no I'm sure
it's about the end of the world so it's
about Judgment Day yep okay hear me out
oh here we go what's the city most
famous for jazz New Orleans what's the
most famous New Orleans jazz song how am
I supposed to know that it could be
anything okay what's the one song in the
whole world that when you're at
Preservation Hall in nor
you have to tip extra for them to
play um When the Saints Go Marching In
right and what's that song about that
song is about Judgment Day Bingo you
just blew my mind yeah okay assuming the
Angels aren't forming a jazz band on
Judgment day but they could be but let's
assume they're not when each of these
trumpets blow calamities
unfold first Hail Fire and Blood rain
onto the Earth seas turn to blood then
Darkness then locusts then a huge Army
of Darkness appears and finally the Ark
of the Covenant is revealed though some
Christians take these doomsday
predictions literally many don't and
non-believers don't believe any of this
but whether you're a Believer or not you
have to admit that it would be
terrifying to hear the sound of trumpets
blowing especially when the sound seems
to be coming from nowhere and everywhere
at the same
time just before midnight on March 17th
2020 the people of houon woke up to Erie
sounds that seem to be coming from the
[Music]
sky creepy even creepier it sounded like
music there's no Machinery nearby or
construction
so I have no idea where it's coming
from
[Music]
weird
a few months later the same sounds were
heard in
[Music]
Argentina this sound was heard all over
the world Denmark Singapore New Zealand
Ireland California really everywhere in
San Antonio The Sounds were less
Musical
oh this is
[Music]
scary and sometimes like in the Czech
Republic it feels like a
[Music]
presence
a dark angry
[Music]
presence sometimes it sounds like the
Roar of an
animal
[Music]
yeah any mention of dragons in the Bible
yep in Revelation the dragon represents
Satan okay this is
terrifying
yeah uh this isn't funny anymore that's
definitely something alive these sounds
are generally known as Sky trumpets and
there are a lot of theories about what
they actually are some scientists say
it's a weather event but Sky trumpets
can be heard in all kinds of weather
even on clear
days some say the sounds are geological
in nature that they come from the
movement of the
[Applause]
earth just have a listen to
this so what are you hearing well we
don't really know now that could be the
Earth moving but what about when the
sounds just go on and
on
some scientists think the sound has
something to do with the Earth's
magnetic field and most people don't
know this but the Aurora Borealis and
Australis they make
sound but the truth is nobody really
knows what causes Sky trumpets they can
sound like music like Machinery or even
like the Roar of a dragon but those
aren't the only unexplained sounds that
come from the sky sometimes on a
perfectly sunny day without a cloud in
sight the sky sounds like it's tearing
itself
apart the iroy lived in Upstate New York
when the early Europeans made contact
one of the first things they warned the
settlers about was the strange noises
that came from the sky the iroy believed
it was the sound of the great spirit
continuing to create the world in rip
vanwinkle which was published in 1819
author Washington Irving references
thunder-like sounds in the Catskill
Mountains the Catskill Mountains had
always been haunted by strange beings
that his father had once seen them in
their Old Dutch dresses playing at nine
pins in the hollow of the mountain and
that he himself had heard one Summer
Afternoon the sound of their ball s like
distant peels of
Thunder The Unexplained booms near Sena
Lake are so commonly heard they've got
their own name The Guns of senica
they've been heard since at least 1850
and they do sound like cannons
firing the earliest record of the guns
of Sena comes from a short story
inspired by the booming sounds that was
published in
1850 it is a sound resembling the
explosion of a heavy piece of artillery
that can be accounted for by none of the
known laws of nature the report is deep
Hollow distant and imposing no
satisfactory theory has ever been
broached to explain these noises the
most that can be said is that such
sounds are heard though at long
intervals and that no one as yet has
succeeded in ascertaining their
cause we call these Sky Quakes and these
skyquakes have been reported all over
the
world like Sky trumpets leading theories
for the cause of skyquakes are the
shifting of tectonic plates or maybe
something to do with the Earth's
magnetic
field a geological explanation would be
easy to prove but so far nothing clearly
something is going on because everybody
in the area can hear Sky trumpets and
Sky Quakes but there are sounds that
only a small percentage of people can
hear and those people are not the lucky
ones
in 1991 the residents of TOS New Mexico
were shaken out of their sleep by a
strange humming sound it was described
as a lowf frequency Rumble like the
sound of a distant engine running well
more like thousands of
[Music]
engines the sound was maddening people
were getting headaches intense nausea
and suffering from insomnia but
strangest of all only about 2% of people
could actually hear it these unlucky few
call themselves The
[Music]
hearers after we moved here within the
first few months I just woke up in the
middle of the night and U heard this
strong humming sound some people can
hear it some people can't some people
like it rattles their teeth and stuff
and like drives them insane and some
people hear it and doesn't bother them
New Mexico is home to several facilities
with sophisticated equipment they teamed
up to study the hum the Los elos
National Lab Sandia National Labs
Philips Air Force laboratory and the
University of New Mexico all
participated in a study high-tech
equipment was set up at a few locations
where the hum was prevalent scientists
collected acoustic geodynamic seismic
magnetic and electromagnetic
measurements but even with all this
modern technology the study was unable
to find the source of the to's hum but
there were increased levels of
electromagnetism in the area during the
study as a result we are left with a
mystery there are no known acoustic
signals that might account for the hum
nor are there any seismic events that
might explain it there are no unusual
lines at suspect frequencies in the
electromagnetic spectrum recorded near
TOs and then just like that the hum was
gone this was a welcome relief for the
people of ta but a few years later a new
hum appeared in Windsor
Canada it's an unsolved mystery keeping
this neighborhood awake at night sounds
like 50 trucks starting up when it when
it's very loud what is it there are a
lot of theories spaceships uh hter space
to American Military um installations
during a single day 22,000 people
complained about the hum researchers
think the sound was coming from nearby
Zug Island where there's a lot of
industrial activity but there's been
industry on the island for a 100 years
the hum is new and it doesn't explain
why only 2% of people could hear it and
that's something interesting 2% of all
people can hear the hum whether they can
hear or not wa what even 2% of deaf
people can hear the hum W hums have
begun popping up all over the world on
every continent the UK Australia New
Zealand India and South Africa all
report hums Sunday it was at its peak
and it was vibrating you could feel it
through your
body and then it starts to die down
again and then you feel it building up
again
it's like the village has been cut in
half this end doesn't seem to experience
anything uh but from Midway downwards
the further down the village you go it
seems to be more and more some are extra
low frequency hums like in t New Mexico
other hums are higher pitched and sound
like running your finger around the rim
of a
glass it's profoundly
annoying as you hear the noise it's hard
to make out what it
is what's the
sound Mo Hussein he took video walking
home one night he's noticed the sound
for over a year I liken it to like some
sort of Alien
Invasion an interesting side note there
was one way the hearers of the hum could
find relief and you're not going to
believe what worked what tinfoil hats YY
yep even just a thin layer of foil was
enough to disrupt the sound and
regardless of the frequency there's
still no solid explanation for the hums
but you can't help but link these sounds
to The Harp array in Alaska
harp is an array of antennas that are
used to study the properties of the
ionosphere but it's rumored that harp
has been used for creating weather
events and for creating earthquakes now
that's considered a fringe Theory but
even the harp project website
acknowledged that experiments were
conducted which used electromagnetic
frequencies to fire puls directed beams
of energy in order to quote temporarily
excite a limited area of the ionosphere
these are just a few of the mysterious
sounds reported on land and in the air
things get really weird when we start
listening
underwater for over 70 years we've had
networks of microphones listening to the
sounds of the sea they're called
hydrophones and they were initially
planted to search for enemy submarines
in 1991 scientists discovered an
unexplained recurring sound known as the
upsweep
oh that's an underwater alien vessel
that is one of the theories the source
of the sound is somewhere between New
Zealand and South America though the
sound is loud enough to travel across
the entire Pacific Ocean alien engines
got big pipes but what's odd is the
sound is seasonal it's heard mostly
during spring and fall aliens probably
take off for the holiday in 1997
scientists picked up a strange sound
coming from from the South Pacific Ocean
this one they called the
bloop that's it I make that sound every
time one of my guppies pulls my
finger no no no that was sped up 16
times at normal speed it sounds very
different
[Laughter]
okay that was weird yeah the sound
lasted almost a full minute and was loud
enough to be picked up by microphones
3,000 M apart now no animal on earth is
this loud and then in 2016 a hydrophone
was sent to the deepest spot on earth
the trough in the Mariana Trench called
Challenger Deep it's 36,000 ft below the
surface that's almost 7 m down the
Mariana Trench is one of of the most
mysterious places on Earth and due to
the high pressure at those depths very
few people have ever seen it so
scientists thought they would listen to
it instead and when they did they heard
moaning mysterious sounds coming from
the ocean tend to have geological
explanations but that sounds like
something
alive and it's not even the strangest
sound recorded in the Mariana Trench a
few years earlier researchers captured a
sound that doesn't sound like an animal
and it doesn't sound geological it
sounds
[Music]
mechanical a short 2 to 4 second complex
sound was recorded that features a 38 HZ
moan with both harmonics and amplitude
modulation followed by broad frequency
metallic sounding sweeps up to 7.5 khz
this sound was recorded regularly during
both fall and spring
surveys they call it the Western Pacific
biot twang biot twang it sounds like
something I used to grow in my dorm room
closet hey come on pal we got kids
watching tomato plants kids I was
growing tomato plants thank you most
relaxing Tomatoes you ever had
again there's no clear explanation for
these sounds but maybe the strangest
sound ever recorded didn't come from the
air or land or the sea it came from
outer
[Music]
space it was the evening of August 15th
1977 the sky over Ohio was clear as
astronomer Jerry aan sat in his basement
office scanning radio signals from deep
space he was volunteering with Ohio
State Unity University's Big Ear radio
telescope working with seti the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence in
other words Jerry was listening for
signs of alien life Jerry was looking at
a print out of sounds recorded a few
days earlier the data reflected the
intensity of the sounds recorded across
a number of different frequencies the
relative intensity was represented by a
number 1 through n and after nine would
move on to letters from A to Z the
typical sounds picked up by Big Ear were
usually relatively low represented by a
one or two basically just background
noise but on August 15th Big Ear picked
up a signal that registered
6eq
J5 that is an unbelievably intense
reading it lasted for 72 seconds and
peaked at an intensity 30 standard
deviations above the sound setting
normally captured now 10 deviations are
rare 30 deviations that's borderline
impossible this was so amazing that
Jerry circled the string of data and red
and wrote wow next to it it's been known
as the wow signal ever since for over 50
years Big Ear listened for radio
emissions at a frequency near 1420 MHz
this is the frequency that hydrogen
naturally emits hydrogen is the most
common element in the universe so this
is a logical way to search for alien
life when Jerry aan spotted a sharp
Spike at that frequency he knew there
was only a small chance that it was
background noise whatever it was the
signal had to be artificial the signal
was also very con concentrated which is
how a deliberate radio signal from
another world would most likely look a
natural event would have been heard
across multiple frequencies the wow
signal was only picked up on this one
the signal was at precisely 1420 356 MHz
now that's too perfect no known
astrophysical source matches the
intensity of the wow signal but the
signal shows no trace of modulation or
data encoded which you'd expect from an
intentional broadcast unless there's
information there that we just can't
understand Saidi tried for years to pick
up the signal again but it never
returned but if aliens were trying to
make contact you'd expect the message to
repeat follow-up studies at Big Ear and
other telescopes have turned up nothing
but in 2012 Earth sent a response 35
years after the wow signal was recorded
the arbo telescope beamed a message
toward the constellation Sagittarius the
source of the original wow signal the
message included 10,000 tweets and
videos from celebrities including Steven
coar and the 2011 Miss Universe tweets
from coar and Miss Universe great now
the aliens are going to think we're
stupid don't take a cheap shot at a
beauty queen I was talking about
[Music]
coar it's hard to identify the sources
of many of these mysterious sounds cuz
they can be far away like the Drone of a
machine in a distant Factory or sounds
generated by events that we can't see
like something deep in the ocean high in
the clouds or or even in deep space but
there are explanations for a lot of
these mysterious sounds according to a
2011 report from the US Geological
Survey Sky Quakes the rumbles heard on a
clear day could be caused by shallow
earthquakes or spontaneous Rock bursts
triggered by mining or from giant waves
breaking offshore or Loosely packed sand
dunes reshaped by strong winds a lot of
o yeah scientists don't really know what
causes skyquakes and the thunder-like
sounds might just be thunder
sometimes when the ground is stable the
sound of thunder can reflect off the
Earth and travel a long distance and
this is a process called ducting this
means the sounds of thunder can be heard
without any visible storm activity some
Sky Quakes might just be noisy fish
sexs I'm sorry what now will male
midshipman fish produce incredibly loud
mating
calls during mating season the sound can
go on for hours Val was what a show off
and when a group of males are competing
for mates they'll try to be the loudest
worst roommate
ever well sometimes these mating sounds
can bounce off buildings and boats in
fact a group of houseboat owners in selo
California once complained about a
strange sound that was loud enough to
wake them up at night they thought it
might be submarines turns out it was
just fish getting down if this fish
balls are and don't come a KN
[Music]
in the hums usually have industrial
explanations building air vents
high-press gas lines high tension power
lines heavy machinery even Sonic booms
and oil Derek but these don't explain
all of them but they do explain most
there's even a theory that a small
percentage of people can actually hear
the resonant sound of the Earth this is
called the world hum though there's no
proof that that
exists the bloop upsweep sounds picked
up by hydrophones could be caused by
underwater volcanoes or the collapse of
underwater caves or glaciers cracking or
Iceberg scraping the ocean floor or
alien vessels I can't prove you
wrong the biot twang recorded in the
Mariana Trench is now believed to be a
previously undiscovered whale call
the complex sound has a lot in common
with other calls attributed to the dwarf
mink
whale and this is a mink
whale there is a problem with this
Theory though the mink whale only makes
the sound during mating season the
botang has been heard all year long so
again just a
theory but there is no working theory
that can explain the wow signal that
Jerry aan discovered in
1977 in 2017 a scientist claimed it was
caused by one of two comets that were
known to be moving through the area at
the time but this theory was eventually
dismissed because the timeline and
location just didn't line up and almost
50 years later the wow signal is
considered by many to be the strongest
evidence we have that there's
intelligent alien life as for the
trumpets it's probably a weather
phenomenon or a geological event and not
a signal that we're approaching Judgment
day but witnesses to these sounds do
feel a range of emotions from confusion
to Absolute
dread I have no idea where it's coming
from Fu
weird oh this is
[Music]
scary and even non-religious people who
hear the trumpets start thinking about
the apocal alypse I once heard a quote
that really hit me it's from Japanese
novelist Haruki Mami he said everyone
deep in their hearts is waiting for the
end of the
world people in all cultures regardless
of Faith have a fascination with
apocalyptic scenarios and we always have
there are many reasons for this religion
the media and just Natural Curiosity but
I think we're obsessed with the end of
the world because of a single Primal
reason control thinking about the
apocalypse allows us to prepare mentally
for the possibility when you watch a
movie about zombies or the aftermath of
nuclear war don't you wonder how you'd
react or if you'd survive well this is a
coping mechanism to help us manage our
emotions now here's a more practical
example when someone dies have you
noticed there are two kinds of people
one person might be overcome with grief
but in someone else the grief just
doesn't seem to hit as hard I'm the
second type of person it's because I
spent a lot of time in my own mind
stressing and preparing for the
inevitable now my dad passed away a
little over a year ago and we were close
and I miss him and I think about him
every day but when he finally died I
wasn't overcome with emotion to some my
reaction seemed like I didn't care but
that's not it he was sick for a long
time and during that time when he was
alive
I thought about his death all the time I
grieved as much as anyone but my grief
was spread out over a couple of years so
when the day finally arrived I was ready
for it now other kinds of people prefer
not to think about death until the
moment is Right upon them now there's
nothing wrong with that those kinds of
people are able to enjoy their time with
a sick family member without dwelling on
dark thoughts it's a more positive way
to live but the grief has to come out if
not over time then all at
once so when we think think about the
end of the world we're spreading those
emotions out a little at a time we're
preparing so if the day finally arrives
we won't be paralyzed the people that
think the end of the world will never
come well those people will be zombie
food right they're not going to make it
but those of us who do like disaster
movies or have a garage full of prepper
gear we're thinking about the end we're
not just preparing physically we're
preparing mentally a little bit at a
time now I bet this is something
hardwired in our DNA by our creator by
God the simulation or whatever you want
to call it it's some kind of survivors
Gene now don't panic people have been
predicting the end of the world for
thousands of years and they've always
been
wrong but although we don't know when
someday they're going to be right that's
100% to fact and when they are I hope
you're
ready thanks so much for hanging out
with us today my my name is AJ you know
Heckle fish verily I say unto thee
greetings and abundant blessings be upon
thy path this day this has been the wi
files if you learned anything had fun do
him a favor subscribe like comment share
that stuff is annoying for me to ask I
know that's it's really annoying to hear
me say it over and over but it really
does help the channel so do us a favor
and click those buttons and like most
topics we cover on the channel today's
was recommended by you so if there's a
story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the Wi files.com tips and if
the end of every wi Files episode makes
you sad and you need more wi files to
keep your day going check out the wi
files Discord it's fun it's free to join
there's thousands of people on there and
it's open 24/7 we keep the crazy coming
all night long and special thanks to our
patrons who make it's good crazy it's
good crazy special thanks to our patrons
to make all this possible I dedicate
every episode to you and I couldn't do
this without you and you guys are
amazing I mean we have the best
community in the business no doubt about
it and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon for as little as three bucks a
month you keep us going you get early
access to videos you get two live
streams a week just for you you get
early access to products like the Heckle
fish plushy why you'd want that I don't
know but people seem to like it and you
get to see the videos before anyone else
without commercials so check us out
that's the patreon page and that's what
keeps this channel moving another great
way to support the channel is maybe grab
something from the wif store grab
yourself a heck ofish coffee mug and
then stuff it with your fist and a heish
fist mug and a shirt and my Heckle fish
it and maybe get one of these Heckle
fish tuget plushy tuet fish Styles
that's going to do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh I play Bia inara 51 a secret Cod
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like
[Music]
iin another conspiracy theory becomes
the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends
I fear the crap cat I got stuck inside
M's home with MK TR I being only to
aware did Stanley Cub Bri fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was cold
I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
when all through the
night all I ever wanted was just the
truth to Fe all through the
night
[Music]
the MTH man Sid and the solar stor still
come to got the the secret city under
ground mysterious number stations planet
to project State and where the dark
Watchers
found in a simulation don't you wor it
though the black KN satell lighted to me
so I can't believe I'm dancing with the
F fish thday
[Music]
night through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth to the Fe all through
night head fish on Thursday night wedn
they J you
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just give
the truth so
theat all through
go
Love
Love Good
Love Good Love to
dance yeah C lovees to dance on the
dance ball because she is a camel when
cam love to dance when the feeling is
right on in time
[Music]
good